and you are looking at four previous  winners of the governor gwen  millennium scholarship who are really  making a difference in the state  the scholarship will be given to four  students majoring in elementary or  secondary education  with an intent to teach in the silver  state these four previous winners shared  their stories virtually to encourage  other people to apply  i'm teaching at the very same high  school i graduated from so uh that's one  thing that i really do  you know implement even in my own you  know teaching life  is uh you know prepping yourself for uh  for uh you know college life and and  that key gpa  that 3.25 gpa that is a necessity you  know to qualify for the millennium  scholarship  the scholarship can be used at a number  of different universities in our state  and it was  created back in 2011 following the death  of former governor kenny gwynn  recipients must commit to teaching in  nevada once they graduate